so at the exact same time the word out
later I've thrown everybody else out
okay so we got a match Jack's intensity
on our normal intros oh not wait no [ __ ]
mark ok mark Jay wait Jack young a [ __ ]
Jack waiting Yami so I miss Bob don't
make that face of me Jack
I can't make any other face don't just
make that no face of me Bonnie
yeah how do you like it away from me
weirdo yeah just somehow when I get
close with the flashlight comes worse
and worse every time I see how do I see
myself
you actually look pretty good mark I do
yeah yeah yeah look you look like fun
baby how do I look you have a camera in
front of your face for some stupid
reason charities the creeper Jack must
be I wasn't looking hang on hey how do
we get started on this map because we
want to guys we press it well [ __ ]
hahaha let's see move wait well whoa
sorry
get away from me Bobby I was trying to
listen I was just trying on my Bonnie
giving me a [ __ ] here no top George
it wasn't very good I can say it was
good yeah I want a phone meniscal I can
hurt Jack okay so we can kill each other
hooray the main black oh come on
those in support of that Yamaha guys
guys guys guys guys just relax guys it's
okay just relax we're all friends it's
okay I don't know about Yami yeah he's
going to just load your bombs over there
oh oh wait
okay all right all right all right get
it on our system Robarts out crowbars
out robots out
robots go and relax hey hey hey taking
pictures of us so sweet sweet how do we
how do we make scary things that later
we obviously later this and as as Freddy
I'm the leader yeah he's already gone
following god damn it let me your golden
Freddy you're not the leader you're just
a creeper with a camera all you got to
do is press them and things happen oh
god there's a net there's an ende
skeleton oh wait so if i turn them all
on are they all gonna do stuff we don't
have the old animatronics yeah oh oh
sorry go back go back to the scary time
now guys pretty soon okay oh the best
the best run began again this is so
goofy you guys you stay out there [ __ ]
you
wait no come out oh can our eyes right
through the gap that's so creepy
hey so creepy hey wait so he can I'm
English no I here angle is Oh are we
about to die oh yeah we need the
exercise
so okay I'll say by the left hand you
guys watch the other vents I guess I'm
gonna get in the right vent there you
good yeah that's good defend it with
your body just kind of in my big fat but
I don't we how do we wind that how do we
won the I think you're gonna go for it
I'm gonna go see if I can wind up the
thing wherever it is if I remember all
for it I thought that was Jax Jung know
what's that joy job my job is to yell at
things okay here stop in the round
okay here's even a very good job yet
Jack hey hey guys oh my god yeah torchy
goes out there's no wind up box how do I
yell at it
disco yellow I wouldn't lead oh oh I
wasn't even yelling at the box I was
yelling at the table to the left of the
box
good job Bob thank you I'm on my way
hey bloom boys here oh I'm so [ __ ] hey
I thought you were your yamimash yeah
back Who am I your fuzzy
okay all right
toy chica is in the far right a party
room what happens if you go Jack go say
hi Detroit you oh oh oh what is that
Jesus everyone Rani's here ready hello
hey hey what do i do what do we do give
away bascillica back okay oh no I'm
stuck Balloon Boy someone kill me oh
yeah Hey gotcha all right then Bianca
hear about you go right out not
appropriate
Oh shark shoot Balloon Boy Jack Walker
okay sure hey what sorry I thought I saw
Balloon Boy
shoot me I didn't shoot anybody what are
you doing here footsteps ah oh Chee
kazeer what do we do at chica holler and
go ahead and go in the room I go talk to
her sorry fussing okay all right Jack
you go say hi mark I know you have a
cupcake
are you are you friendly no chica
umm problem we still there why is she
still there no there
hi I'm Park whoa max your makers are
[ __ ] like Megan Megan blue where's
Megan oh wait wait wait
the lights not working lights not
working oh look the low points on your
angle here we go yeah take him back
perfectly spoon in the risk
you're not allowed to go okay yes
we're not loving out of here yeah that's
what I'm doing we're gonna flank him
give him a sneak attack don't were no no
no oh I'm all right got a good but I'm
free they don't work hmm
let's go row row right yes go Oh what
the hell is going on here right hi bye
wait I made it out wait come here who's
here who's here
whoa oh they're they're gonna kill II
know not what them walls Bank is like
hey you guys having fun is this what
they but they're just hanging out this
is likely when you catch the Toy Story
toys just like hanging out yeah Freddy
was Freddy when they killed us first
hi Freddy you gonna suck yes uh-huh uh
yeah we're no the Freddy crew the Freddy
brother here you know yeah we'll just
get up on stage and replace them okay
here we go all right show you the world
oh not this again
shining shimmering splendid
yeah um holy world
there we go perfect exactly where is the
box that's right here where is the box
here
hey go [ __ ] yourself
sound stopped right when you did that on
mine what happened not surprising q5
Jack yelled in the game was just like
whoa sorry man oh thanks Freddie
oh here he is oh wow he's way bigger
than you are
hey whoa hey what are you saying sir
he's much bigger than not about size oh
I'm gonna put her back in no no let's
try this again I'm sure it'll work this
time a little boy home we can push them
farther beyond and now Jack Jack it's
revenge' balloon boy I can't even walk
come on oh wait oh God oh no sob oh
thank you wait I don't know hang on I
got it hey hey gimme gimme gimme
ah Oh cuz you keep pulling it together
just - got it
uh uh-oh a blue boys over here what the
hell
wait wha what wait what wait wait
dealing with her what this is the
balloon wall we have no choice this is
no no no serious this is a different
balloon boy yeah we have two balloon
boys yay yeah uh why am I stuck in me
they're hot balloon hang on I got you
the power
we ain't got say I trotty oh oh no not
like that
there I saved you thank you know I'm so
dang it to hell you know slow and steady
oh I just wanted to start my own show
with my own balloon boys up on stage all
by myself
Oh goddamnit oh no no no you can't no I
don't have it anymore it was just
bouncing from room to room but this is
sort of a [ __ ] ow
well yeah try it again wow sounds gonna
be huh sounds gonna be oh oh oh
nickels at the front okay ha through the
door I'm picking up late well I I'm
missing a mango ha ha
are you decided uh well no I'm not err
you can't no huh
you can't kill me oh yeah what a shot
hey wait wait wait
you stand there at the table and I run
as fast as I can and you have to try and
hit me at the end at home ok ok I like
this game 3 - what ah
I look on it now we better wander around
and die seriously